hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll we've
talked about dna and genomes here on the
podcast quite a bit there's a lot of
information
locked up in our dna both information
about how we as organisms or other
organisms function right in the here and
now but also there's information about
our history remember a few months ago we
talked with bachelor kachar about
paleogenomics learning about very very
early life by looking at the current
genomes of different organisms and
seeing what they have in common but if
you want to look at
human history you're talking about
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
years ago not billions of years ago and
that gives you a different thing that
you can do you can look at the actual
dna of the actual humans from tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
years ago can't do that if you're
looking a billion years ago there's no
dna left from a billion years ago so
this is a new field of science that has
really exploded in the past decade or
two learning about ancient human history
by looking at the actual genomes from
skeletons and fossils of real human
beings who lived back then and today's
guest david reich is one of the world's
leaders in this field
he's made many discoveries along these
lines in his lab perhaps most
provocatively he's one of the people who
discovered the fact that there is
neanderthal dna
in most human beings today other than uh
africans other than people who whose
ancestors had been in africa the whole
time most other human beings have a tiny
amount of neanderthal dna mixed in so
this tells you something since
neanderthals were europeans and asians
predominantly and human beings homo
sapiens came out of africa what this
means is that when the humans came out
of africa they got it on with some
neanderthals right they mixed up the
gene pools a little bit and that kind of
analysis can be done at many layers in
many different times and we learn a lot
a lot of surprising discoveries have
been made i don't want to give away all
the surprising discoveries david will
tell us about them but there's this idea
that has come about of ghost populations
you know you find some archaeological
find and look so there's some
civilization or some settling maybe it's
not really civilization but some group
of human beings they used certain tools
or they hunted or they gathered or
whatever but how are they related to
other groups of human beings the dna is
telling us this and so the ghost
populations are populations of people
who no longer exist but there's little
genomic remnants little trace signals in
the dna of other human beings that lets
us indicate that they were there and
think about how they related
historically to other populations we can
use this dna evidence in conjunction
with evidence from archaeology and
language and even written history to put
together a much more nuanced and complex
view of how human beings have developed
ever since human beings came on the
scene roughly 160 000 years ago so again
this is one of those areas which we like
to do on mindscape where it's kind of
brand new you know anything that didn't
exist when i was a graduate student as
far as i'm concerned is completely brand
new and that means that we're just the
beginning of figuring out what we're
learning but david has interesting
things to say about human behavior and
history in africa europe asia the
americas the whole bit lots of surprises
along the way so let's go
[Music]
david reich welcome to the mindscape
podcast hi
i have to start with one i'm using
anecdote because i get many people on
the podcast in many different areas and
without trying i keep noticing that a
lot of people even though they're doing
you know neuroscience or philosophy they
had some physics in their background i
promise i'm not trying to do that but
indeed i noticed on wikipedia somewhere
that you have a little bit of physics in
your background yeah i got an
undergraduate degree
and so that means that
i studied physics formally for a few
years but i didn't go on to get a
graduate degree
or do
develop a real expertise in any
particular area but you actually not
just took courses but got a degree in
physics sure uh my bachelor's degree is
in physics did you have hopes to become
particle physicist or astrophysicist i
applied to grad school in atomic optical
and molecular physics
and i was gonna go to berkeley uh but i
deferred it and i ended up getting
distracted
distracted in a good way clearly does
the physics education color how you do
your
uh dna research these days i think so i
think that a lot of my work relies on um
trying to be
sophisticated about quantitative
thinking about the data that we produce
and that we the laboratory is a kind of
hybrid laboratory that both generates
data but very much also develops
methodology that's data driven in order
to be able to analyze the data in new
ways and that's always been central to
our laboratory in fact even the primary
thing
and i think i'm able to do that uh
because i have this quantitative
background that's very nice and it is a
there's a revolution going on so uh but
let's explain because i think we've
talked on the podcast before
about paleogenomics right about learning
about early life from modern genomes
given that there's a certain diversity
of life and they have certain things in
common you can say things about the past
but that's not exactly what you're doing
you're actually taking advantage of
digging up bones of human beings and
looking at their dna yeah that's right
and so if your interest is in
deep deep time and trying to understand
the history of life uh the time scales
you're interested in are millions tens
of millions and hundreds of millions
maybe even in some cases thousands of
millions years but ancient dna dna
doesn't really preserve more than a
million years and mostly doesn't
preserve more than hundreds of thousands
of years so if your question is to try
to understand events uh
for example associated with mammalian
radiations and dispersals it's not going
to help you very much but what it does
do is it actively and powerfully
interrogates the last tens of thousands
and maybe hundreds of thousands of years
and so modern humans descend largely
from a common ancestral population in
the last 200 000 years and so what we
can do with ancient dna is sample dna
from all around the worlds from known
times and places in archaeological sites
and see how the people whose dna we
obtain is related to
each other the other sites and also to
people today and that allows us to
understand how the diversity of the
world got to be the way it is today and
what's actually quite interesting is
that when one does this when you look at
the dna from
ancient archaeological sites and see
test how it's related to other
archaeological sites and people today
it's consistently surprising and so the
reconstructions one makes from
populations living today are often quite
different from the reconstructions you
you you make when
when you actually looked at dna from
known times and places and that's
telling you that people have moved
around too much such that the present
day diversity around the world has
obscured what was there before and is
your team actually going out there and
digging up bones or do you partner with
the archaeologists who are digging up
the bones it's almost all partnership
with um hundreds of archaeologists
around the world we work with on variety
of projects they'll throw you a bone
quite literally and you will take out as
dna is this something that we've known
how to do for a long time or is that
actually part of what is new and and fun
so the ancient dna field has been around
for maybe 40 years but it's only become
really serious in the last 10 years um
and it's been around a little 40 years
because people for the first time were
convincingly getting snippets of dna out
of old samples but really until 10 years
ago the only substantial amounts of dna
people were getting were from the
mitochondrial sequences the
mitochondrial sequences are the energy
factories of cells
it's about 16 000 dna units dna letters
long and that's about 1 200 000th of the
human genome in size
it's only a small fraction of our genome
and it contains the record of our
mother's mother's mother's mother's
mother an entirely maternal lineage
which is of course fascinating important
but it's limited in terms of its
statistical information it provides
about the past because it's only a
single statistical instantiation of the
evolutionary process recorded in
mitochondrial dna but of course the
whole genome records not just one's
mother's mother's mother's mother but
one's mother's mother's father and one's
mother's father's mothers uh all of
one's genealogical ancestors at least
possibly in practice tens of or hundreds
of thousands and with all that data one
could obtain precise information about
how people are related to each other and
i mean maybe good background uh
distinguishing between mitochondrial dna
and nuclear dna what do we call the rest
of the dna
so your dna is packaged into 47 units in
your cells in the great majority of your
cells 23 pairs of chromosomes
and your mitochondrial sequence your
mitochondrial sequence is carried in the
eggs that the
your mother's egg is fertilized and it
occurs in several thousand copies
typically per cell but each cell also
has uh one copy each of those forty six
dna packets the chromosomes that come in
23 pairs so the copy number of them is
much lower than that of the
mitochondrial dna but there's much much
more information in them 200 000 times
more of your dna is in them and that's
where almost all the genetic information
is encoded
it used to be that people studied
mitochondrial dna because it occurred in
thousands of times more copies that was
good as good given how degraded the
material it is maybe that's where you
start because you have a better shot of
pulling it out if you have several
orders of magnitude more material to
start with but with the new techniques
we can actually work with everything and
are the new techniques just uh
cheaper is that the real um well i mean
effectively for your purposes is the
reason why there's been a revolution the
last ten years just because it's easier
to reliably sequence those uh the
ancient dna or have we learned something
sort of qualitatively different about
how to analyze it i think it's all of
those things but it's technically driven
as many of these things are and uh we're
probably getting dna out with maybe
eight or nine orders of magnitude more
efficiency than we were uh 13 years ago
efficiency in this case means cost say
okay
and the reasons are number one uh short
read sequencing which is the dna
sequencing revolution
which made sequencing literally 10 to
the fifth to 10 to the sixth times more
cheaper than it used to be and that
happened in the late 2000s
and
another reason is that the only way it
was possible before
to study dna was to use polymerase chain
reaction pcr which required
pulling out segments of dna
by putting
unique primers down on top of the dna
and that would end up sacrificing maybe
30 or 40 dna letters just in order to
pull out the sequence but the typical
fragments of ancient dna are only about
40 or 50 bases so if you sacrifice over
almost everything just in order to pull
it out there's almost nothing left and
so
what was happening is it was incredibly
expensive to sequence and the only way
people were able to pull it out was by
polymerase chain reaction which lost
almost all of the target and so there
was almost nothing left there have been
major technical biochemical improvements
that have massively increased the
efficiency of the extraction the purity
of the extraction so all of those are
improvements as well and the result has
been was that beginning in 2009 2010 it
became possible to generate whole genome
sequence data from human remains
thousands tens of thousands in some
cases hundreds of thousands of years old
but when you say whole genome um are we
only getting 30 or 40 base pairs well
where the dna is naturally fragmented by
the degradation process into fragments
that are rarely more than 70 or 60 bases
long and the typical length that we get
from sequencing is maybe 30 or 40 or 50
bases um but there are billions and
billions of molecules even in a degraded
dna extract and by brute forcing it or
using various tricks we can get
many hundreds of millions of independent
dna fragments and puzzle together uh
genome scales worth of data good that's
what we need for background for the dna
how about background for uh the
evolution of human beings because uh
it's always very confusing to me there's
a lot of names of different species and
subspecies um what what is the big
picture story let's say
from when humans and other primates
split which was a few million years ago
so our closest living relatives are the
chimpanzees and bonobos
and slightly more distant to that is
gorillas
the chimpanzees and bonobo lineage split
from hours probably somewhere between
five to seven
million maybe eight million years ago uh
uh
it's not even completely clear where
that occurred um you mean where
geography where geographically that
occurred um
and uh the guerrillas a couple of
million years earlier than that uh in
the intervening time uh the uh lineage
leading to modern humans was certainly
at some times almost certainly was in
parts of africa although not necessarily
during the whole time
leaving skeletons like the
australopithecines and the art
epiphacenes and the early homo human
lineages like homo habilis and homo
erectus which also dispersed to diverse
places in eurasia already about 2
million years ago
at which point the threat is not clear
anymore where the ancestors of people
of humans
primary humans were lived but
beginning maybe five or four hundred
thousand years ago it's absolutely clear
uh that the modern human lineage giving
rise to the great majority of people
today is again in africa um and the
earliest skeletal remains of people
whose skeletons look anatomically modern
are two to three hundred thousand years
ago in different parts of africa and
then there is an explosion of
anatomically modern humans out of africa
in the near east between fifty and a
hundred thousand years ago that
disperses around eurasia and eventually
uh very quickly also to australia and
new guinea and then after 15 000 years
ago into the americas and then in the
last couple of thousand years to the
last habitable places on earth
and i mean that means we're very young
right like species-wise you know we
split off from chimps and bonumbos
millions of years ago but modern humans
only came into existence maybe 200 000
years ago or maybe three or four hundred
thousand years ago not clear and there's
uh and
uh
only seventy thousand years ago there
were at least five groups living around
the world that we know about today
through a combination of skeletal
analysis
and dna data that were each as different
from each other much more different from
each other than any groups living today
the most diverse living groups living
today but within a few tens of thousands
of years we were alone on the planet um
these groups kind of uh
were subsumed within mixed with or
displaced by the expansion of modern
humans or at the same time as modern
humans were expanding
so it's not clear how young we are
comparatively
to me it's not i think it's sometimes
exaggerated how young we are or how
non-diverse we are if you look for
example compared to chimpanzees
today chimpanzees western chimpanzees if
i remember right uh
have about as much diversity as humans
do uh but there are also some other
chimpanzee groups like central
chimpanzees and eastern chimpanzees and
nigerian chimpanzees and together all of
those chimpanzees are more diverse than
modern humans are but perhaps they would
not have been more diverse than humans
were 70 000 years ago
when you give the charity how much
impact will your donation actually have
this question can be hard if not
impossible to answer most charities
can't tell you how your money will be
used or how much good it will
accomplished
if you want to help people living in
poverty with evidence-based high-impact
charities i recommend you check out
givewell givewell spends over 20 000
hours each year researching charitable
organizations one of my favorite ways to
donate is to their maximum impact fund
which spreads money to important places
at the end of each fiscal quarter over
50 000 donors have used givewell to
donate more than 750 million dollars
rigorous evidence suggests these
donations will save tens of thousands of
lives and improve the lives of millions
more and the best part is give well is
free give what wants to empower as many
donors as possible to make informed
decisions about their donations they
allocate your tax-deductible donation to
the charity you choose without taking a
cut so go to givewell.org to read more
about their research or donate to any of
their recommended charities that's
givewell.org and enter mindscape at
checkout so they know we sent you
well so it is an interesting thing um we
are taught about evolution of various
species and you see speciation in
different branches and so forth
but this human story you know reminds us
that
it's hard to draw fast lines between
species and what what counts as a
species like you say there was a lot of
i should put words in your mouth um
a hundred thousand years ago there were
organisms that were sort of close to
human that were all over the place but
were they different species or were they
sort of different subspecies how would
you describe it i think that's a
philosophical question and as a
biologist and as a geneticist i'm
actually not so interested in philosophy
and uh what is a species it's not
particularly important to me uh i've
thought about that topic a lot a lot of
people are interested in that topic and
in fact our collaborative team has
thought about the that topic and we
punted on it uh we did not we refused to
engage with it so
in 2010 uh i was lucky to be part of a
team that
was able to sequence
dna from a
tip of a finger bone from a cave in
siberia and we obtained incredibly high
quality dna from this tip of a finger
bone and it turned out not to be from
any known human group it tended it was
from a group that was almost as
different from uh
neanderthals neanderthals were from
human it was a separated by many
hundreds of thousands of years maybe
four hundred thousand years from
anything we had seen before so it was
incredibly exciting we didn't have any
archaeology that had pointed there to
being a different group living in this
region and so it's incredibly exciting
to have this data and some of the people
on our team wanted to call this a new
species name that's one of the ambitions
of many paleoanthropologists to have a
paper which coined a new species name
the name was going to be homo altaiensis
um you know human from the altai um and
we had a long debate and discussion in
our team
and we decided to just call it by a
common colloquial name denisovans and
the reason we decided to do this was
that it was completely unclear to us
what a species is the classic biological
definition philosophically is determined
by maybe the biological species concept
uh originally suggested by the biologist
ernst meyer who argued that species are
groups of organisms that do not in
practice interbreed with each other and
what we had seen in our genetic data is
that these groups were interbreeding
with each other and so and we're able to
form successful
uh
mixed groups like all of non-africans
today who are the descendants of
mixtures between neanderthals and modern
humans or like people in new guinea
today who are descendants of mixtures
between the neanderthals and modern
humans so if the definition is that
mixtures of groups do not incur and do
not lead to successful uh populations if
they do occur then our situation did not
qualify
on the other hand the physical
anthropologists have argued to us quite
often and said well the neanderthals
must be a different species not by the
biological species concept but by the
morphological species concept they're so
different from each other in terms of
their forms they need to be considered a
different species they're very
specialized i don't have an opinion it
feels very philosophical to me and i'm
not so interested in philosophy i love
philosophy but i get that there are good
philosophical questions and less useful
ones right but is there a way of uh from
a more scientific perspective at least
saying that there was greater diversity
of human forms a hundred thousand years
ago than there is today
or is even that that's absolutely
correct so if you actually there you can
imagine some kind of measure of um
variation amongst populations living
around the world um maybe that
measure of variation is that if you take
two random individuals from you know
geographically around the world what is
their average genetic differentiation
from each other and how much larger is
that compared to the differentiation
within the population that's known as
fst it's a measure of how the variation
is partitioned and it would have been
larger seventy thousand years ago or a
hundred thousand years ago than it is
today today that number is maybe point
one um and uh that may end or point uh
it depends on how you compute it but on
average the amount of genetic difference
between
two individuals or two genomes within a
population is uh six times greater than
the average across two populations so
only a small amount of the variation
existing within humans today is across
population variation but amongst
chimpanzees today and amongst humans
many tens of thousands of years ago that
would have been a relatively higher
proportion okay that makes sense and
let's uh let's zoom in on this um
because there's a there's a famous and
incredibly fascinating example of you
know the humans the
predecessors of modern humans
fan out from africa 50 000 years ago and
one of the places they go is to europe
or eurasia maybe and they meet the
neanderthals so one question is is it
neanderthals or neanderthals is there an
h in there i've seen it either way
um they're both correct in the english
language well that's too bad so uh in
our papers we've used both depending on
journal style fair enough i grew up with
neanderthals that's probably what i'm
gonna try to stick with but uh
neanderthals again they can clearly
interbreed because that's what they did
right and so how recent is this
understanding and what exactly did we
learn yeah so
uh neanderthals from archaeology are an
incredibly impressive
group of humans that lived in western
eurasia not just europe but also places
like central asia and even to parts of
east asia probably so there's a debate
about how far east they ranged
neanderthals appear clearly in the
skeletal record a few hundred thousand
years ago uh and late neanderthals
persist in europe until about 40 000
years ago at which point they seem to
disappear from the skeletal record as a
distinct group of um humans um
neanderthals in europe late neanderthals
as well as earlier neanderthals were
large they were
as big or bigger than modern humans
their brain capacities were as large or
larger than those of modern humans
even though their skulls were
differently distributed
you said as large or larger or larger so
if you do allometrically scaled uh brain
uh brain capacity uh it's just as large
or larger um and uh they're also larger
individuals
and
and they made complex tools that
are
must require a rich amount of learning
and skill
in order to
create
and uh had been doing so for hundreds of
thousands of years um prior to the time
they disappeared uh so these humans
occupied western eurasia and we know
they encountered modern humans as modern
humans expanded out of africa in the
near east we know that because we can
see the archaeological and skeletal
remains of modern humans as they expand
out of africa in their near east between
150 000 years ago and we can also see
sites for example in parts of france
where there are
neanderthals and modern humans living
side by side and altering alternating
occupations the same caves we can see
that less sharply in the near east in
places like present-day israel and the
mount carmel region where you can again
also see neanderthals in modern humans
but not clearly at the same time the way
you can see them in europe but in fact
it seems likely they were living there
at the same time in interbred because
that's the most likely location where
the interbreeding probably occurred and
uh so a question has always been as
modern humans expanded out of africa in
the near east to what how did they
interact with these other impressive
humans who they encountered who were
using at least initially similarly
complex and sophisticated uh economic
and life history strategies and the
genetic data beginning in the 80s
seem to be suggesting that modern humans
people living all around the world today
shared no dna that was
plausibly derived from a group like
neanderthals all modern humans for
example on the mitochondrial dna the
maternal inherited dna or also on the
paternal dna on the y chromosome all
seemed to descend from a common ancestor
in the last couple of hundred thousand
years which was highly unlikely to come
from a group like neanderthals which
would minimally have diverged many
hundreds of thousands of years or even a
million years ago people thought at the
time and so sorry had that been true
would we have thought that that's
because the modern humans
wiped them out or just couldn't
interbreed with them or was there even a
theory multiple possible explanations uh
some population geneticists people in my
field argued that there could not have
been very much interbreeding because we
know from studies in ecology of lots of
different species that if there's even a
little bit of interbreeding when a small
pioneer group even with a
advantage spreads into
a region occupied by a group that's more
well established and larger in
population as you might imagine modern
humans might do as they expand it into a
territory previously occupied by
neanderthals if this occurs even with a
low rate of interbreeding they'll
eventually be swamping of the nuclear
genome by the genetic material coming in
from the larger group if the process is
not instantaneous and so again and again
in different types of
of animals you see this nuclear swamping
effect during a range expansion such
that even though the population that
migrates out is successful ecologically
genetically
the existing population somehow leaves a
major imprint there was no evidence of
that and so it suggested suggested that
maybe there was very very little
interbreeding or if there was
interbreeding there were some kinds of
incompatibilities either um that they
call as they call uh
um
uh you know either socially or
biologically and causing these groups to
interbreed so when i went to grad school
that was the orthodoxy that was the
situation we thought there was no
evidence amongst modern humans of uh
divergent ancestry that might be
consistent with substantial
interbreeding with a group like
neanderthals
okay but
so i mean i think that the one of the
questions that we were interested in
once we knew that we could obtain genome
scale data from neanderthals once svante
papa's group working in leipzig made it
clear that they would be able to get
clean and with scale data from
neanderthals which happened in the last
years of the 2000s and they pulled
together a consortium which i had lucky
was lucky to be involved with once it
became clear that that was going to be
possible
there were a number of questions and one
of them is what is the relationship of
neanderthals to modern humans one of
those questions is did they interbreed
with non-africa with people they
encountered like non-africans the top
candidate would have been the ancestors
of europeans
and there were other questions like when
did this lineage split from that of
modern humans um would it have been you
know a few hundred thousand years ago
would it have been a million years ago
so these were the types of questions we
were after
and so when we looked at the data that
was my job to study the relationship
amongst these groups along with other
people we were working with uh the one
of the questions we asked of course was
are they more closely related to some
humans than to others living today
because that would be perhaps a sign of
inter-breeding if there was
interbreeding with some humans more than
others and then you might expect the
descendants of those humans to be more
closely related and when we looked at
the data we saw such a signal
and we were actually quite incredulous
at that signal because
i certainly came from a background which
thought there was no such signal and so
i was very skeptical
and also some features the signal were
surprising there was no excess signal in
europeans um in fact the signal in east
asians was just as strong
and so that was surprising too because
east asians there were no neanderthals
in east asia and so this was really
seemed to be a sharp divide between
sub-saharan africa and um eurasia and
the rest of the non-african populations
so that was surprising too so what we
did over the next couple of years is we
really wrestled with this observation we
thought maybe this is a
artifact of our dirty data of you know
various problems with our data that
might occur contamination which had
afflicted our field
and so we tested the data in various
ways and stratified the data in various
ways uh looked at various types of this
type data looked at various types of
modern human data looked at various
technical processings of the data
computationally and developed several
different statistical techniques which
would
independently look at different types of
information that is recorded in genetic
data about how populations are related
to each other and they were all pointing
very clearly
and consistently at a history of
interbreeding
so essentially every
population of people here on earth uh
does have some neanderthal dna in them
other than the ones who stayed in africa
uh that's close to true although uh
sub-saharan africans
today
uh
to us many sub-saharan africans today
have some degree of
neanderthal ancestry possibly due to
small amounts of back to africa gene
flows over the last tens of thousands of
years and we can't currently rule out
some persistent neanderthal exchange but
it's at a much much lower level if at
all so what does this teach us i mean
what are we then thinking about the
relationship between the early humans
and the neanderthals were they
friends uh or you know or did did they
go to war and capture some slaves is
that something that we can even hope to
answer
i think we could probably
hope
or we should try to learn more than we
currently know but currently there's a
number of alternative scenarios that are
consistent with the data i'm not trying
to mince words at all
but
what is clearly the case based on the
archaeology not based on the genetics is
that when neanderthals and modern humans
encountered each other there was a
period of coexistence but that the
coexistence in any one geographic region
was limited in time you know at most a
couple of thousand years in the parts of
western europe where it's been looked at
most carefully and the neanderthals
quickly disappear however it's also true
that a lot of the modern human groups
that
they coexisted with also disappear so
it's not obvious that the neanderthals
were out-competed by modern humans in
fact there's some archaeological
evidence that some of the neanderthals
even picked up modern human technology
and learned from them um and
especially in france where there is some
archaeological evidence from this but
after about 39 000 years ago
many of the early modern human
archaeological cultures that are evident
in europe for that time as well as
neanderthals disappear and are replaced
by a relatively homogeneous
archaeological culture that potentially
re-expands from one place maybe even the
near east so it's not just that the
neanderthals disappear it's that there's
many human groups disappearing one of
them or multiple of them are
neanderthals and whether that's because
modern humans displaced neanderthals
because they had a more um
different psychology that sort of was
incompatible with coexistence or a
different life history strategy or
whether there was active conflict over
limited resources or whether they were
just more modern humans because they had
a different economic strategy that
allowed them to exploit the environment
more intensively and the neanderthals
just got absorbed through mixture we
don't know okay okay because i was going
to ask but i think you just answered it
should we
broadly think of the if we were drawing
these diagrams of species coming up on a
tree through time should we think of
neanderthals ending or being absorbed
back into the rest of humanity and maybe
the answer is we just don't know well i
think that's a philosophical question
which is probably interesting
okay good but we could at least
delineate which philosophical questions
are interesting or not uh okay so i mean
that was and this was you know a
revolutionary discovery this is not what
people really thought like you just said
i mean this is something that we've
learned very recently about
the genomic history of modern humans
that's right it's this and many many
other findings from the
application of this technology have been
shocking and surprising and again all
within the last 10 years it's safe to
say roughly speaking that you have a
graph at some point of the number of
genomes that have been sequenced this is
sort of like single digits for a long
time and then just explodes yeah that's
right and so for example in 2009 it was
zero
and in 2010 it was five
and maybe in 2014 it was maybe 40 or so
and now it's well over seven thousand
okay so we're learning a lot so uh
and now we're at the point where it's
just so many interesting things going on
that i want to hit some of the
highlights and then feel free to chime
in if i'm missing a highlight but
clearly there's a lot of action in
europe
um post the intermingling of modern
humans and neanderthals right so i mean
i have here my notes roughly between
four and ten thousand years ago there
were different populations in europe and
so one one question is is it
j do we
think that there's all this diversity
that we know about in europe just
because we've studied europe more or do
you think that it's a it's a reflection
of the actual um migration patterns and
so forth um i think that
everyone who thinks about
this data should think about the data
from europe
not as indicating that europe is in any
way a special place but just as a
reflection of what's possible to do when
one has a lot of data and the reason we
have so much data from europe is for
several reasons one is that it's uh in
european laboratories that uh the
technology uh for doing this work
developed first and it's also european
archaeologists who have been uh pretty
um
consistent over the last century and a
half at assembling skeletal material and
keeping it in museums and other
collections and so
and there's also
resources in europe and in the united
states uh and uh for doing this kind of
work
and the field's so young that people are
now only reporting the dna
that they started working on even though
it's rapidly expanding to other parts of
the world so europe's not more important
than other places of the world but it's
a place that you can use almost as a
kind of laboratory to understand what's
possible with applying this type of
technology to learn about the past
and what we now have is many many
thousands of whole genome data datasets
published and many many more unpublished
more than we have published
that provide a nearly gapless record of
european population history and space
and time over the last ten thousand
years with a more gappy record between
about 50 000 and 10 000 years um and
that's an incredibly
powerful resource we are locked in two
dimensions today in terms of our
understanding of human uh variation but
we now have a third and in europe it
goes back deep in time um and it's dense
and it's possible to do things that we
couldn't do before
and there's a sense in which
if you apply this sort of logic to or
this this sort of way of thinking to
europeans today they're all one
population in a way that they there were
different populations in the near past
that's right i mean i think that
europeans today are not one population
there's substantial variation amongst
europeans and more broadly western
eurasians or people who are called
caucasians or white on the u.s census
but there's actually pretty substantial
differences amongst these groups but
they're genetically much more similar to
each other everybody in that category
usually than for example europeans
already east asians today um and it
wasn't always so uh so if you look in
the places where um 400 years ago people
of that u.s census category would have
lived the level of differentiation
amongst those groups a few hundred years
ago would have been similar to what it
is now but roll back 8 000 years and
there would be many groups in that
region as different from each other as
europeans and east asians are so when
this was one of the many senses in which
uh people's intuitions including mine
were wrong about the past if you had
asked me uh in i don't know 2002 what
would be the level of differentiation
within europe uh 10 000 years ago i
would have guessed that it would have
been relatively modest uh that this
region like today would have been a
region of relative genetic homogeneity
but in fact you look at the data that's
completely not the case and if you were
to assign census categories in the past
they would have broken down along
completely different fault lines from
the way you break them down today so the
past is not really uh well described by
the present it's
very important to keep that in mind and
one of the things we see again and again
with ancient dna data is when one goes
and collects dna from archaeological
contexts
that have never been interrogated before
with this technology and makes a guess
beforehand about what how these people
would be related to people living
afterward and people living today almost
always that guess is wrong and often
profoundly wrong and you know we know
this now not just in europe but in many
many places in east africa multiple
places in east africa in south central
africa places like malawi in cameroon
in india
in pakistan in central asia in east asia
in japan
in multiple parts of the americas
essentially everywhere
almost we see patterns like this where
again and again you see that groups in
the south pacific
that are
not directly ancestral or primarily
ancestral to people living today i like
the way you put it that there were
populations in what we think of as
europe
8 000 years ago that were as different
from each other as modern europeans are
different from east asians that's that's
something we can visualize a little bit
how much do we know about these
populations and and in particular
there's this wonderful idea of a ghost
population like a whole group of people
that we don't even wouldn't even think
existed just on the basis of looking at
who exists today and moving backwards
only through looking at dna did we
realize oh there's this whole kind of
person that we didn't know existed
right so ghost populations are groups
that emerge out of models so when you
write down a statistical model a
mathematical model for trying to
understand how you derive the ancestry
of present day populations from previous
populations models are never perfect but
you write down a model and you can do a
goodness of fit test to the data and you
could say oh this population is a
mixture of um two three four ancestral
populations at different times in the
past and when you do such a model for
example for present-day european
populations to first approximation many
european populations today can be
relatively well described as a mixture
of three ancestral populations we knew
that already in 2014
and
you can ask what do those three
ancestral populations look like in order
to fit the data and in fact none of
those populations exist any exist today
the one that's closest to existing today
are groups like present-day sardinians
but even sardinians are not a perfect
proxy for one of those three ancestral
populations what happened is that these
three ingredients uh source populations
for present-day europeans are predicted
based on the genetic data
of people today but they're not
present anymore because they got mixed
together and they exist in different
mixed proportions and people living
today so what often happens is when you
look at modern data or a mixture of
modern and ancient data
you can see that there probably was or
there must have been or there
parsimoniously was a
earlier population that now no longer
exists in mixed form but contributed
substantially to one or more populations
living today that's what we call a ghost
population a population we reconstruct
statistically from groups living today
but we don't have samples from today and
what we find again and again with dna is
we predict these populations and then we
see them once we obtain dna from the
right time in place so we see them in
the archaeological data in the in the
bones and the dna from the bones that
we're actually doing correct yeah okay
so and are the
yamnaya one of these am i pronouncing it
correctly that's right that's a ghost
population
so the yamnaya are a
group of people who are archaeologically
were
expand about five thousand years ago uh
across the steps north of the black and
caspian seas um the earliest yamanaya
are probably north of the black and
caspian sea somewhere maybe in the dawn
or the niapa river valleys or in the
volga river valleys uh but uh they
develop in a new economy uh that is
based on at least two major inventions
that didn't exist prior to the time that
they expanded that weren't used in those
regions before one of them is the
invention of the wheel
which was invented uh
around that time and we don't even know
who invented it first because once it
was invented it spread like wildfire but
plausibly it was the umnaya
it's not obviously not the alumni but
it's not obviously them either and they
certainly picked it up pretty fast and
the other was the domestication of the
horse
and it was probably not fully
domesticated yet but they were using
domesticated horse and domesticated
herds and they took their wagons and
they pitched them to domesticated
animals
and they moved them out into the open
step lands which had been previously
uninhabitable because they were far away
from water but they were able to take
their supplies out into these regions
and graze much larger herds than was
possible before on the large biological
resources for example the grasslands of
the steppe and these people expanded
very dramatically so instead of uh prior
to this time there were many diverse
archaeological cultures making different
types of ceramics and pots but after the
yamana expand there's a monoculture and
homogeneity across the vast region all
the way from central europe hungary all
the way to mongolia as these people
expand very rapidly um it was not known
uh
how this impacted the populations of
places that had been previously and
continue to be densely settled like
europe but we now know from the genetic
data that this was a massive impact so
in northern europe more than half the
ancestry of many northern parts of
europe today descends from this
expansion
and it's not necessarily like an empire
right like with a central uh ruler or
anything like that but the culture of
these people like you said spread from
europe to east to central asia
that's right yeah so i think that the
and the dna from these people
spreads from all of these places and so
i think that many archaeologists would
tell you do not confuse this with an
invasion and they'd be right to
emphasize that i mean maybe in uh this
is about the time of the earliest
egyptian civilization so maybe there
there would be uh capacity for an
invasion and for organized state society
but up on the steps there would not have
been that type of organized state
society in the same way uh we do not
know uh to what extent this was
systematic uh rating or uh exploitation
some people argue it might have been
some people argue it might not have been
but in any case this group was uh very
effective in terms of expanding um and
there's a number of arguments about you
know whether this was related to
economic exploitations of niches that
were not previously exploited related to
grazing or use of new technologies or to
what extent this was active and you know
um involuntary displacement i mean since
there's so much that we don't know is it
is it uh a responsible speculation to
wonder whether they might have been more
centrally organized than we give them
credit for that i mean there might have
been a
5 000 or 8 000 year old
empire that uh really did answer to a
single government so this is not my
expertise but i'm almost certain the
answer is very powerfully
that that would be extremely unlikely
okay so these people were highly
decentralized there's no evidence of and
there's a lot of archaeology there's no
evidence of
centers of power or uh central
settlements
there's no evidence of large
congregations of individuals there's no
evidence of systematic you know war-like
events even though there is evidence
perhaps or there could be evidence maybe
of raiding and certainly kinds of
evidence of violence i think people if
they were interested in violence as a
kind of uh
mechanism for these groups expanding
would be more interested in ideas like
cattle rating or resource rating or you
know um
you know raids on other communities to
take um
you know by men after women or various
things like that but not organized in a
large way people argue that uh mythology
spoken uh in europe and india today uh
associated with indo-european
language-speaking cultures has shared
traits that might descend from a
population that spread these languages
and some of that shared mythology and
people try to reconstruct some of the
shared values in these um ancestral uh
indo-european language speakers and
people argue based on this that this
would have been a society that was
focused on uh
on on on
on practices like cattle rating or uh
uh various male-centered expansion
practices that are seen in kind of
distorted reflected form in indic
mythology and nordic mythology and greek
mythology and so on well and the the
application of uh gender to these
questions is not purely hypothetical
right because we can separately look at
the dna from the patrilineal line in the
metroline line by looking at y
chromosomes and mitochondrial dna and x
chromosomes in the rest of the genome
because x chromosome is a kind of female
colored chromosome because two-thirds of
the x-chromosomes running around in the
world today are in women compared to uh
only one third in men whereas for the
rest of the nuclear dna it's half and
half and so you can kind of the x
chromosomes huge compared to the other
parts of mitochondrial dna and y
chromosome which are only one
instantiation of the evolutionary
process whereas the x chromosome is
thousands and so it's actually contains
quite a lot of information so even
though the information is in some sense
not as crisp as that of the y chromosome
and mitochondrial dna it's arguably in
some cases may be usually balanced out
by the many many independent flips of
the evolutionary coin allowing one to
learn more precisely how groups are
related to each other and so by looking
at the x chromosome and solving the
system of equations where in one case
it's two-thirds one-third and for the
rest of the genome it's one-half
one-half one can extrapolate out what
the male and female contribution to
different events would have been and so
we have that tool available to us too to
understand the process of sex bias in
mixture processes of different
populations and presumably
unsurprisingly uh one's guess is correct
that there are certain men out there who
are very good at spreading their seed
all over the world
that we have our most recent common male
ancestor is probably more recent than
our most recent common female ancestor
that's the opposite is true actually so
uh no i think your argument is correct
the argument was right and the truth the
oldest common male ancestor is about
twice as deep as that of the most recent
common female ancestor so we estimate
based on counting mutations since a
common ancestor which serves as a
molecular clock and knowing what the
mutation accumulation rate is
approximately we estimate that the
common female ancestor is roughly 150 to
180 000 years ago
approximately that and until recently we
thought that that was about the same for
the y chromosome but then um a personal
ancestry
group studying african americans found a
y chromosome type that was twice as deep
in african americans and then surveys in
africa found a higher frequency of this
type specifically in cameroon uh where
there's a number of groups that have a
substantial frequency of this y
chromosome type which has persisted but
in studies of many many many many tens
or even hundreds of thousands of people
nobody has found a mitochondrial
sequence older than this this one so
um
it's actually quite interesting the y
chromosome and mitochondrial dynamics
spread around the world uh mitochondrial
differentiation across groups tends to
be lower on a short geographic scale and
potentially higher on a large geographic
scale whereas the y chromosomes are the
opposite so females and males migrate at
different
at different scales so in a lot of
communities but this is not true
exclusively women are the ones who move
between communities so so
many communities but not all communities
are patra local or vera local
and so you'll have typically men will
range less far from their homesteads
than women so you might have i don't
know in a model in a diffusion model you
might have in this community women on
average diffusing 10 kilometers or 20
kilometers from their homestead and men
maybe not as much and so that type of
process will result in mixing on a scale
of tens or hundreds of kilometers
but long long range migration and so
that uh on the mitochondrial sequences
but long long range mitochondrial
movements seem to be human movements
seem often to be propelled to a larger
extent by male movement okay and so that
would produce more homogenization uh y
chromosomally on a large scale so
there's a scaling factor geographically
um that is not obvious so women diffuse
a little bit more quickly but men either
stay at home or go way far away
maybe yeah on a scale of thousands of
years with exceptions
there's always going to be exceptions i
think we can take that uh for granted
here i i was going to ask about
how we should envision what is actually
going on in these migrations is it like
hundreds or thousands of people picking
up stakes and moving from one place to
another or is it you know a few
explorers going out or do we have any
idea about something like that i think
we have an increasing amount of
information about that process but that
is one of the big open interesting
questions that can be addressed in
principle and that we have a lot of
um
possible technical ways to make progress
in addressing through looking at this
type of data but um i think that uh in
different instances uh there are
different um
different uh
um
processes that one might imagine are
occurring
so yeah you did you mentioned something
very provocative i want to get back to
uh if it's we're talking 5 000 years ago
or even 8 000 years ago we have language
right these people could talk to at
least their friends is that fair
and uh maybe we can relate the spread of
language and the fact that there's
something called indo-european as a
precursor of many modern languages can
we can we help understand that by
understanding how these populations
moved around because it was always
surprising to me that india which seems
pretty isolated from europe in ancient
history in my brain uh shared this sort
of language family with us that's been
surprising to people for more than 200
years ever since it was noticed by
people who
learned sanskrit and also had learned
latin and greek and noticed that these
uh ancient languages were pretty similar
to each other as well as the languages
derived from them or related to them
it's been a big mystery about why people
across such a broad region
all the way from india to
the atlantic tours of europe spoke
similar languages and places also like
armenia and actually archaeological work
has since uncovered uh
indo-european-speaking peoples and
places where indo-european languages are
not commonly spoken today including
early divergent forms of them for
example in anatolia spoken by the
hittites several thousand years ago um
and uh even in the eastern deserts of
the present-day territory of china
and so um it's been a big mystery how
these uh languages got to spread so far
and we know from ethnographic studies
that languages tend to spread through
movements of people
and so
uh large-scale movements of people
although there are exceptions to that
where there's elite population
conversions of the languages as occurred
for example in hungary um but usually
it's through large-scale movements of
people so one is tempted to argue that
there were movements of people that were
vectors for spreads of these languages
and since the time scale over which
languages are discernibly related to
each other is really
only shallow at some level it's really
not more than 10 000 years and some
people even think that's a stretch in
terms of reconstruction of shared
languages
that provides us information or
hypotheses that we can test with genetic
data about how particular language
groups spread indo-european languages
are an amazing instance but by no means
the only instance of amazing language
spreads one of the most amazing is the
spread of austronesian languages these
are the languages spoken throughout the
pacific
and uh with the most diversity in the
present in in aboriginal peoples of
taiwan but spoken throughout the pacific
from easter island in new zealand and
hawaii uh through many many of the
islands of the pacific through indonesia
almost all indonesian languages are
austronesian and even madagascar off the
eastern coast of africa speak these
languages this expansion occurred just
in the last three or four thousand years
and is geographically uh and humanly at
least as dramatic as that of
indo-european and there too there's a
question of the movements of people that
spread these languages but there's
others as well everywhere in many many
places in the world but indo-european is
an amazing example and one of several
where we have strong insights from the
genetic data well and for the
austronesians uh what do we know is the
genetic data helpful there or is it not
just not there yet we haven't figured it
out yes it's super helpful maybe even
more clarifying in some ways than the
indo-european language data at this
point so linguistically the deepest
roots of austronesian languages are in
uh taiwan as i mentioned if you look at
aboriginal groups in taiwan and study
their languages and build a tree of how
those languages are related to each
other into the ones spoken in this much
vaster region
the deepest roots of that language tree
the earliest splitting ones are all in
taiwan there's like eight or nine or so
deep splits and all but one of them are
in taiwan in taiwan okay and then there
is a cascade of splits that are
reconstructed that suggest a possible
expansion route through the philippines
and then
in different branches both toward
western uh
western parts of indonesia and also
eastward
jumping
into places like the open pacific for
the first time like vanuatu fiji samoa
tonga and then bursting even further out
into polynesia
and so there's this whole cascade of
linguistic bifurcations that has been
used to argue for possible spreads of
people the genetic data
creates a tracer dye if you look at
taiwanese aboriginal related ancestry
that is present in essentially all
groups that speak these languages
including in madagascar who are admixed
with mostly sub-saharan african ancestry
but about a third austronesian ancestry
that's hardly present or not present in
the rest of mainland africa and is
consistent with being spread by these
movements of people so what we see in
the indo-european case and also in the
austronesian case are these tracer dies
which are distinctive genetic uh
frequency distributions that are
characteristic or of the ghost
population that you think may have
originally spread these languages and
the genetics adds to the linguistic data
in allowing one to trace the possible
and likely movements of it one
particular case that's very interesting
about this in the case of
the austronesian language spread
is that
first spreads that brought people out
into the previously uninhabited islands
of the pacific the last uh major
uninhabited uh uh habitable places uh
for humans on earth which were really
only began to be inhabited about 3000
years ago so uh humans get to um the
solomon islands and um bismarck islands
archipelagos off the coast of new guinea
and australia
about 40 or 50 30 40 50 000 years ago
very anciently very close soon after the
original spread of modern humans out of
africa and stop uh so there's other
islands not so distant well they are
pretty distant but not so distant from
those that are empty of humans and then
after 3000 years ago they began to be
peopled by humans and that's they're
peopled by people using ocean faring
technology that was invented by these
almost certainly by these austronesian
speakers who use it to spread from
from the philippines and ultimately from
taiwan uh
skirting the coast of new guinea and
then they make it to places like vanuatu
and new caledonia and eventually and
quickly fiji and tonga and so on and
these people are able to go over large
ocean spaces and navigate much earlier
than other chinese and european
navigators were able to cross these
large large ocean spaces if you look at
the genetics of the first people who
break this ancestry they look almost
entirely east asian like taiwanese
aboriginals but the people who live in
vanuatu today have almost no ancestry
from this group and what you see is
there's this initial expansion 3000
years ago or so that gets to vanuatu
with almost entirely taiwanese related
ancestry today it's maybe only 10
and then maybe 500 years later there's a
massive wave from new guinea
from people related to present-day new
guineas that almost completely displaces
the local population
sporadically in different ways in
different parts of the islands and
leaves only ultimately maybe 10 from
this initial wave that may not even be
originally mostly from vanuatu itself
but from other groups that were picked
up along the way
it's a very sex bias process where
primarily male people from new guinea
mix with these sea going ocean people
you might have thought that the sea
going
technologists from uh ultimately from
taiwan might be the your bias might be
to think that those are the expanding
males but it's not true it's the papuans
who are the male biased expanding
population in that case so there's many
instances like this that we're learning
about from dna and that are very
surprising this was a surprise when what
it might have thought that the mixed
populations of the pacific's with both
large amounts of papuan ancestry and all
of them and large amounts of
taiwanese ancestry and at least some of
them
including polynesians where it's maybe
75 percent
might be evidence of a long drawn-out
process of expansion but when you look
at the data it's a nearly unadmixed
initial taiwanese-related expansion
followed by uh massive movements from
new guinea a place where most people in
their prejudiced picture of the world
might not expect large-scale movements
of people but in fact it's the primary
ancestry of many of these groups
so it's a it's an extremely dynamic
picture of uh human beings it's not like
a population goes takes over a land and
just
dominates it for the next 10 000 years
right like there's waves of people
coming all over the place in europe and
everywhere else yeah and i think we
forget that in our cultural memory i
mean i you know come from a jewish
background right from europe that's
where my
second degree and third degree ancestors
are from and
you know the history of jews in europe
in northern europe is one where people
kind of get comfortable become
integrated in the community
and are
valuable valued members of their
community or
at least
tolerated members of their community for
a couple of generations and then there's
a pogrom and the community's wiped out
and it's a disaster everybody's worried
and then they kind of come back you know
the next generation they get comfortable
they think they kind of forget that
there was a problem and then a few
generations later there's another pogrom
so i think on a deeper longer time scale
i think human uh history is often like
this people often have a picture in
their mind that the descend they descend
from people who have been there forever
and that there hasn't been migration and
mixture between groups that are quite
different and maybe even alien is not an
important part of their past but in fact
looking at genetic data makes it
absolutely clear
that there are very few if maybe no
groups in the world that don't have
major mixture as part of their history
so i think that's a bigger sort of
pattern that becomes very clear when one
studies this type of data which is that
migration and mixture are very central
and integral to us when we think at the
temporal scale of many thousands or tens
of thousands of years yeah it's longer
than a human lifetime so we just think
that anything longer than 100 years is
permanent as far as that's where most
people are concerned but there are two
examples you have many many wonderful
examples in the book and i encourage
people to read it but there are two that
i i don't want to let pass by without
talking about them uh india and the
americas i mean we already mentioned
india a little bit but what was
remarkable is the idea that these sort
of population flows can be relevant to
the caste system in india today uh
there's sort of different populations
that uh
have a rough correspondence to to how
indians live today is that a fair thing
to say
uh i think that there is correlation to
the capital correlations
to the to the caste hierarchies and
variation the caste system in india is i
think very hard to understand for
everybody including for me and certainly
hard to understand for people outside of
the system um but has multiple uh
aspects to it including a kind of um
organization into strata
of people who are in a sort of hierarchy
and maybe five or four strata of priests
and you know warriors or rulers or
merchants and uh commoners and people
who are outside the cast system and
people who are uh you know even lower on
the scale so that's one stratification
but there's also stratification into
groups that have different local
economic and tribal identities and
there's at least 5000 of those groups
and many of them are endogamous they
really don't mix with other groups uh
even those they live amongst and the
genetic data that we've
studied this has been probably the
single biggest focus of my laboratory
over the last 12 years the genetic data
shows that many of these groups really
have not mixed with very much with other
groups they've lived amongst for
thousands of years and you can see the
signatures of that in the genetic data
where groups that may today have
population of a couple of million people
in fact have lived by gal next to other
groups and in fact have through social
norms uh made it almost impossible for
members of their groups uh to mix with
neighbors so what you have in india is
to some extent a frozen
picture of the structure that existed
thousands or a couple of thousand years
ago after the system locked in at least
in the ancestry of some of these groups
so maybe it makes it possible to use
present day groups to go back a little
bit deeper in time and to record a
little bit about what the population
structure might have been like a couple
of things
where there's more mixture and there's
less sort of um barriers amongst groups
although there are still barriers
amongst groups in some groups in
in in europe so uh what you see in india
is that there are gradients there people
in india today
have a very complicated mix of ancestry
but many groups in india today can be
relatively well approximated
statistically as a mixture as a
mathematical mixture of two ancestral
populations uh one could be called the
ancestral north indians
which are a group that are relatively
more closely related to central asians
and middle easterners and europeans
ultimately um
and another is called the ancestral
south indians who have bear much less
relationship to those groups and we've
known that since 2009 um and we now know
through analysis this is crazy reason
i'm sorry
we now know this through analysis of
ancient dna and these groups are quite
different from each other kind of as
different from each other as europeans
and east asians and people range all
across the spectrum of proportions from
these groups although everybody is mixed
there are exceptions to this but most
people fall in this category and they
follow the two major language groups in
india dravidian and indo-european
but
um
uh those two groups we now know from
co-analysis with ancient dna are
themselves mixed uh more anciently of
three more ancient groups
one is an iranian-related group one is a
step pastoralist related group and
another a third is a ancient southeast
asian uh related group related to
indigenous southeast asians new guineans
uh andamanese islanders and uh more
tribal uh groups from southeast asia
would all of these qualify as ghost
populations or some so these would all
be ghost populations that no longer
exist in unmixed form uh but we have
them uh all sampled in dna and in fact
the andamanese we have directly sampled
without real with relatively little
mixture um and we're not arguing these
people come from the andaman islanders
but rather that the andamanese descend
from a group that
had little mixture of compared to the
group that's actually the true source
population so this is a model for south
asians today and if you look at the
proportion of ancestry from pastoralists
it's not very high in india today it's
never more than about 20 and it goes
down to almost zero percent in some
groups um but we can tell that that step
ancestry pulsed into india between 4 000
and 3500 years ago by comparison to
diverse genetic data we have from
central asians and people from the
northern parts of south asia we know
exactly when it comes in it's relatively
much higher in frequency and people who
are of traditionally such higher social
status in the indian caste system and
it's especially high frequency adjusting
for other factors in people who are from
the traditionally
custodians of the indo-european um
texts like the brahmins and bhumihars
in
the
indo-european texts and so this suggests
that uh this step ancestry is associated
with indo-european associated culture in
south asia adding another line of
evidence to this pulse of ancestry from
the step about 4 000 to 3 500 years ago
uh with earlier ancestry from the alumni
we talked about before being responsible
for spreading these languages into india
and militating against other
explanations for the spread of these
languages there's very strong evidence
now from genetic data that cross iranian
plateau spread is very unlikely and i
was going to say that the time scale is
about that of the rig veda right the uh
the classic indian text that is still
very important to modern india
yeah critical as well as many other
texts but people reconstruct the writing
of the rig veda to
maybe three to four thousand years ago
and uh that uh would be consistent with
a rising something around this time of
this spread you'll probably do a whole
podcast just on that but i i know that
you have to go so let me just ask a
little bit about the americas because i
was fascinated to learn there is one of
the populations that settled in the
americas is called the first americans
but it turns out they were not the first
americans yeah it's a kind of
tautological kind of
name first americans and you know in
some ways maybe it's not an ideal name
because it's a statement about
priority or about
history in the name itself and maybe we
should try to avoid such names um in the
future uh but uh
almost all the ancestry of native
americans uh prior to uh today uh that
doesn't come from european and african
migrants in the last 500 years comes
from a single ancestral group that we
call first americans
that likely spread into the americas
maybe around 15 000 years ago or before
across almost certainly across the
bering land bridge from eurasia we know
a lot about that group we have many
early skeletons from that group although
not from the earliest times and we
actually know about their earlier
formation from different strands of
ancestry present in eurasia and um
represented by different ghost
populations represented from dna data so
that's very interesting um however
there are hints in the genetic data
maybe strong hints that actually the
earliest spreads in the americas were
not homogeneous and in fact there might
have been a substructured spread of
modern humans into the americas after 15
000 years ago the americas was
uninhabited by humans before that time
or much before that time although
there's now increasing hints in the data
in the archaeological data maybe people
argue there might have been earlier
presence but large-scale occupation
really begins only after 15 or even
after somewhat after that time um and in
brazil in particular there are some
groups that bear relatively more close
relatedness to people in southeast asia
in australia and new guinea then do the
early spreads than the major population
so that suggests the possibility that
the early spread is substructured and a
later expansion maybe 12 000 or 13 000
years ago
of people um that are the primary nat
first american population created small
pockets of remaining groups that exist
in mixed form in some parts of the
americas today like amazonia and bear
greater relationship attesting to this
earlier
population spread it would be really
exciting to get ancient dna that has a
large proportion of ancestry from this
group i am not 100 sure this group even
really existed these are four sigma
effects you know i don't know i don't
think they rise to higgs boson level of
uh significance and so maybe we should
see
treat them uh treat them as not yet uh
compelling
well this is a perfect uh segue into the
final question which is where are we
going i mean this whole field is so
young like i i have this slight
resistance to the existence of any field
that came into existence after i got my
phd but still okay new sciences come
along all the time um
what are the next steps where are we
going in the in the decades to come what
should people be looking out for in the
front page of the new york times
well i think it's been a bit of a wild
west field it's been uh really exciting
every new sample has every new sample
from a previously unexcavated
archaeological context has been
incredibly exciting so we're a little
bit in the kind of
prospecting phase where there's been an
emphasis on getting even one or a few
samples from a
previously unknown archaeological
context and the field is also in the
hands of the technicians so um the
people who know how to generate this
data
reliably and convincingly
and also people who are custodians of
the
set of tools both laboratory tools and
technical tools to convincingly analyze
the data now this creates a sort of kind
of like a bit of a problem because the
actual people who know the most about
the topics that are being interrogated
are um
are not the people who are doing the
primary research um and so the uh
someone like myself can um have you know
the great privilege of uh analyzing data
on the one hand from vanuatu data on the
other hand from europe um and learning
about all these places but i'm not
really deeply trained to know the
context we have to collaborate with
archaeologists and we try to do that and
we aim to do that but really the future
is one where the people who really know
about these topics will be able to learn
enough about these fields to use the
technology to address the questions that
they know are most interesting and i
think that transition is now happening
in the last couple of years
and for example we have a paper coming
out in two weeks which is a really good
example of that uh it's a case a paper
where we were writing a paper on the
history of britain in the last few
thousand years and
and we were reporting data from 793
individuals in one paper that paper is
going to be published in december 22nd
and dumped in the back of the paper was
a family tree we had reconstructed from
a single tomb in britain from about 100
years after farmers got there almost 6
000 years ago so in this
figure we had found a big family that
we've now reconstructed 27 people all
buried in the same tomb all we know
exactly how they're related to each
other and this co-author of our paper
which had 223 authors almost all of them
archaeologists who had contributed
samples to this large paper uh he had
contributed some samples not relevant to
that story but something else but he
noticed this data and he said that's my
expertise i spent almost all my time
looking at cotswold severed long cairns
in southern england dating from this
time and there's all these
archaeological questions about their
meaning and what they meant to their
communities
and i'd like to look harder at that so
he talked to one of our geneticist
co-authors and they looked really hard
at this family and what we can tell is
that the tomb was one where it was
entirely patrilineal everybody buried in
the tomb
descends from the same uh patriarch who
reproduced with four women and we can
see that and
it wasn't a normal uh patrol locality
though and because uh
kinship and fatherhood was defined not
just biologically but we actually see
multiple cases of adoption so uh it's uh
this man and his descendants adopted
other sons uh from that their wives
previously had with other men and
incorporated them into the pedigree so
what we're seeing is a community where
there were different rules of kinship
and you can learn about that it answers
questions for these people and these
archaeologists about um what these tombs
meant to the people who used them and
it's the kind of thing that i think
archaeologists are particularly excited
about it's the kind of study that
archaeologists can lead and so that's um
i think sort of the future one of the
features of this field which is really
taking this technology and midwifing it
and handing it and translating it and
transferring it to the people who really
can pose the questions the best i've
seen genomics field after genomics field
doing this i remember genome-wide
association analysis which i've done a
lot of work in especially in the 2000s
trying to see associations diseases like
diabetes or prostate cancer i remember
those studies originally were carried
out in studies of hundreds or thousands
of individuals
by geneticists who were technicians who
really knew how to carry out these
studies but quickly these were
transferred to the hands of the
epidemiologists the people who really
knew the questions best and were able to
assemble cohorts of hundreds of
thousands of people and that's where
that field is now and that's where
genetics and ancient dna are going i
foresee uh specialization in the future
but it sure is exciting to be there on
the ground floor when you can do the
americas in africa and europe and asia
all at the same time and so uh david
reich thanks very much for giving us
this introduction to a really exciting
time good thank you
[Music]
you